كايتلين كولينز من آه أنت في
القاعة أعتقد أنك كنت تصرخ
بسؤال آه ماذا رأيت من
نقطة المراقبة الخاصة بك، نعم كنا نحاول
استدعاء
ما لا يمكنك رؤيته بالكاميرا،
ربما نكون على بعد حوالي 50 قدمًا  من ذلك
الباب الذي دخل منه الرئيس السابق ترامب للتو،
انعطف يسارًا وذهب إلى
نفس قاعة المحكمة حيث رأيت
محاميه يدخلون أيضًا مساعديه جيسون
ميلر قبل أن يدخل إبستاين ومحاموه
معه، سألناه
وقال محاميه الآخر كريس كاي  أنه
سيأتي إلى الكاميرات ويتحدث، ومن
الواضح أنه لم يفعل، لذلك ذهب مباشرة
إلى الغرفة التي كانوا خلف تلك الأبواب
لعدة دقائق
ودخل المحامون أولاً ثم
بوريس إبستين ثم ترامب يليه
جيسون ميلر فقط لإعطائك فرصة  إحساس
بخلافة من رأيته يسير في
تلك الأبواب، أريد أيضًا أن أعرف
شخصًا آخر موجود هنا، وهو والتون ألتا، وهو
خادم البيت الأبيض السابق
لترامب والذي أصبح الآن مساعدًا شخصيًا له
في مار آلاغو.  الذي كان في الواقع
شاهدًا رئيسيًا في
التحقيق في المستندات، وهو هنا أيضًا
يرافق ترامب في هذه الرحلة، وهو الآن
في تلك الغرفة يتم قراءة
لائحة الاتهام، ومن الواضح أنه
سيدخل The Plea بنفسه، وقد قيل لنا أننا
سنرى ما إذا كان ذلك بالفعل  يقف أو إذا كان
المحامون ومن المحتمل أن
يأتي ويتحدث إلينا بعد ذلك
فهو يعلم أننا هنا وحاولنا
إقناعه بالإجابة على سؤال يدور في الغرفة